parler rapidement de brigitte macron qui
reçoit reçoit il a une habitation à la
main jeremstar l'influencent heures donc
à l'elysée alors pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas parce qu a pas de sujet
jeremstar voilà c'est un jeune garçon
qui s'est fait connaître dans pas mal
d'émissions au début ce n'était ni tout
le temps et choqué après les faits les
interviews de personnalités de télé
réalité dans des baignoires
il dénonçait un peu les dessous de la
télé réalité c'était un peu le zorro il
est arrivé sur ces 8 et une sale affaire
un petit peu de 2,2 de bonnes sale
affaire dont il a été victime dont il a
été victime à la présomption d'innocence
et puis bon il a été remercié de ses 8
et aujourd'hui voilà est-ce que ce jeune
garçon est la meilleure personne pour
représenter donc le harcèlement on va
dire la lutte contre le harcèlement en
france musique mâcon va le recevoir est
ce que vous êtes choqués ou pas choqué
et je sais que sébastien tu as des as
fait tu as des infos là dessus et après
je suis bien à part la dalle et le morro
évidemment qui n'a pas plus parler alors
non il va pas être reçue à l'elysée
abba et pose partout qu'il a une il
aurait garé là il a reçu une réponse de
l'elysée à 1 et coimères valeurs comme
n'importe quelle personne en fait qui va
écrire à brigitte mâcon va recevoir une
réponse mais sauf que il a reçu une
réponse de pierre olivier costa qui est
son directeur de cabinet je suis bien
persuadé que brigitte mâcon c'est pas
elle qui répond elle est même pas au
courant il sait même pas qui c'est donc
lui essaye de faire le buzz avec cette
réponse mais demain n'importe qui dans
le caddie de réponse l'écrit aura une
réponse négative maison qu'est ce que
jeremstar en revanche pour représenter
la lutte contre le cyber harcèlement
c'est la meilleure personne daniel non
je suis en train d'apprendre qu'il
s'appelle jérémy gisclon formidable non
mais moi je trouve que c'est judicieux
qui est une réponse alors en fait c'est
une fin de non-recevoir très policé
d'accord c'est une réponse très très
officielle mais je trouve ça bien parce
que comme ce monsieur à la culture du
buzz s'il n'avait pas reçu de réponse il
aurait peut-être et s'est créé un buzz
voilà le genre cmb riche le mari ne
s'intéressent pas à ce que je fais pour
le harcèlement et que ça et moi je ne
suis pas choqué parce que même s'il ya
eu aussi c'est un personnage un peu
sulfureux il parla tellement de jeunes
est tellement de jeunes l'écoutent que
je pense que sa mère qui reprirent sa
jeunesse pour ça la question est-ce
qu'il ya quand même une jeunesse qui
fait des études qu'elle maîtrise en
droit était
toute la jeunesse n'est pas celle qu'on
voit à la télé des gens de la ville à
des coeurs brisés des radars c'est fini
par le super jumbo cyberharcèlement donc
forcément c'est son du tout mais mathieu
65 % des jeunes aujourd'hui entre 20 et
25 ans ont déjà été cyber harceler avant
d'être harcelé à l'école
et puis bon bah ça s'arrêtait quand on
sortait de l'école éventuellement on
avait quelques lettres anonymes et
compagnie maintenant quand avec les
réseaux sociaux c'est non-stop c'est
sans arrêt on peut être harcelés en
permanence le simple fait de parler du à
ce manque est une cause qui qui depuis
lundi dernier que prend le ministre de
l'éducation nationale est comment dire à
brigitte macron c'est formidable c'est
bien j'aurai pas eu il y aurait pas eu
ce garçon là on n'aurait jamais abordé
décrit bien mal à courir les pays
clients ont aussi une influence auprès
s'il échoue parce que tout le monde
connait pas boire donc et une aussi une
influence euse qui est là le seul truc
qui est important dans le jeu dans le
harcèlement c'est d'en parler c'est tout
il faut en parler si quelqu'un est
harcelée il faut en parler à sa famille
et à des numéros comme le 30 vin vient
exprès partir seul et c'est très bien au
contraire pas faire une heure de
sucreries n'est pas reçue juste myriam
et puis on passait au sujet d'après
s'émouvoir franchement je t'adore j'ai
rien contre jeremstar mais quand même
c'était la personne qui a recelé lui
même les gens de télé réalité en sortant
des trucs de fou sur son site
donc un moment c'est un peu le chat
commet collectif larose a touché son mea
culpa il a un peu diminué mais c'est
facile à gagner beaucoup d'argent aussi
avec le chevalier blanc sûr mais on sens
où l'entend c'est donc par un légume
séverine et on s'en fout on en parle
tout à l'heure un bad buzz est un bon
buzz
oui c'est bien ici tu montes tu t'es
fait ça on en parlera sait bien que ce
n'est pas parce que c'est halal mais
vous êtes fâché avec ce garçon ge energy
a connu tous très bien les concours de
[ __ ] en général c'est dans votre lycée
pas sur le plateau
[Applaudissements]
ben franchement l'homme descend du singe
mais c'est incroyable bond en avant se
faisait m'énerve
le retard les amis on n'attend pas les
jambes pour le coup en revanche gm j'ai
rien contre lui il est pas là le coup il
essaie très maire déléguée d'ecs et le
rayon rien